Biogas erneuerbare Energie und dennoch
umstritten was kann es leisten und zur
Energiewende beitragen kann es helfen
teure erdgasimporte zu
verringern Biogasanlagen können
tatsächlich viel beitragen und vor allem
auch zur flexiblen Bereitstellung von
Energie sprich wenn die Sonne nicht
scheint und Windenergie nicht zur
Verfügung steht und da ist Biogas ein
wichtiger Baustein davon z von Biogas
kann jeder Haushalt beitragen durch
sorgfältige Mülltrennung das Ziel ist es
hier möglichst viel CO2
einzusparen um eben das Klima dann zu
schützen doch Biogas hat auch
Kritiker sie bemengeln die Verschwendung
von landwirtschaftlichen
Anbauflächen wenn wir darauf
Energiepflanzen anbauen einzig um
Energie zu erzeugen dann besetzen wir
große Teile der Ackerflächen auf den
Ackerflächen sollte viel mehr
Nahrungsmittel angebaut
[Musik]
werden Stadtreinigung Berlin hier wird
ein besonderer Müll sortiert Müll aus
der Biotonne Speisereste Küchenabfälle
also die Berliner Stadtreinigung lässt
diese Abfälle nicht wie üblich auf dem
Komposthaufen verrotten sondern
verwandelt sie in wertvolles
Gas jeden Morgen in der Früh verlassen
die LKW der Stadtreinigung den
Hof die Fahrer hier sammeln an diesem
Tag nur den Abfall aus der Biotonne ein
insgesamt den ganz Berlin 75 000 Tonn
pro Jahr
[Musik]
Endstation für die Fahrer eine
gigantische
müllsammelhalle Betriebsleiter Wilhelm
Winkelmann kontrolliert hier die Abläufe
bei der Entsorgung des biomülls wenn der
so aussieht wie er da jetzt aussieht
dann ist es auch so dass das relativ
viel Küchenabfälle drin sind und diese
Küchenabfälle die bringen sehr viel
Gas aus dieser schmutzigen
abfallmischung soll ein absolut sauberes
Gas entstehen für diese Biogaserzeugung
braucht es spezielle Anlagen in denen
die Abfälle vergoren
werden und so funktioniert eine
Biogasanlage Pflanzenreste Gülle oder
eben Biomüll werden in einem Fermenter
bei 40 bis 50° etwa 3 Wochen lang verg
das entstehende Gas wird gereinigt und
mit einem Blockheizkraftwerk entweder
zur stromwärmeversorgung eingesetzt oder
in das Gasnetz
eingespeist dieses Biogas das ist das
spezielle wird nicht zu Strom
umgewandelt sondern in unserem Fall ins
Netz eingespeist ins Erdgasnetz und dann
an drei Tankstellen benutzt um 165
Sammelfahrzeuge zu betreiben
das sind über die Hälfte der Berliner
Müllwagen die bereits Biogas als
Treibstoff nutzen und so CO2
einsparen insgesamt liefern gut 9000
Biogasanlagen in Deutschland Energie 90%
in Form von Strom und
Wärme landwirtschaftliche leeranstalt
Triesdorf in Bayern hier wurde 1985 die
erste Biogasanlage in Deutschland
errichtet heute ein kleines Museum der
damalige Leiter der Schule Johann
sedelmeier hat diese Anlage einst
entwickelt diese biogasgeschichte haben
wir der Natur nachgemacht wir
haben das was der bansen auch macht eine
vergehrung unter bestimmten Temperaturen
und damit eine Umsetzung und so die
Energie zu
nutzen die Verdauung wie sie in einem
kuhmagen geschieht wird in der
Biogasanlage
nachgearmt das Museum in Triesdorf zeigt
wie einfach es ist unabhängig zu werden
von fossilen
Energien als sich auch im Alpenvorland
immer mehr Massentierhaltung entwickelte
wussten die Bauer nicht wohin mit der
Gülle statt sie auf den Feldern zu
verteilen wurden sie dann in Fermentern
vergehrt die Geburtsstunde der
Biogasanlage
der Anfang war dass
viele gesagt Biogas hatten wir schon
zuvor das ist noch nie irgendwas
geworden das sind nur Spinner die solche
Dinge machen und so weiter aber
dann ja hat das ganze umgeschlagen wie
man damit
so Geld machen konnte dass H auch ein
wirschaftlicher Aspekt plötzlich
dahinter
war das deutsche
BiomasseForschungsZentrum in Leipzig ins
Leben gerufen 2008 vom
Bundeslandwirtschaftsministerium aktuell
arbeitet man dort auch an der Frage in
wie weit Biogas russisches Erdgas
ersetzen kann und gibt sich optimistisch
Biogasanlagen können tatsächlich viel
beitragen momentan haben wir insgesamt
Energie Versorgung von 100 stunden im
Jahr wobei das nicht nur elektrische
Energie ist sondern auch Wärmeenergie
und damit können wir ein bedeutenden
Anteil zur
Energiewende beitragen und vor allem
auch zur flexiblen Bereitstellung von
Energie sprich wenn die Sonne nicht
scheint und Windenergie nicht zur
Verfügung steht das kann so keine andere
Technologie momentan letztendes
leisten gemessen am deutschen
Gasverbrauch von 1400 terwattstunden ist
das nicht wenig
dennoch das Umweltbundesamt sieht die
Technologie heute kritisch sofern Biogas
aus Energiepflanzen wie Mais gewonnen
werde sei es
ineffizient unter bestimmten
Voraussetzungen vor allem in kleinen
Ortschaften kann die Versorgung mit
Biogas wiederum Sinn
[Musik]
machen Jazz kassiker live gespielt in
der norddeutschen Provinz
der Konzertsaal für das Publikum aus der
Region eine umgebaute Scheune in dem
Dorf blewig in Meklenburg
Vorpommern 140 Jahre alt ist dieser
imposante Backsteinbau es war eins die
größte Scheune in Deutschland bis das
kleine gut 600 Einwohner zählende Dorf
auf die Idee kam das riesige Gebäude
umzubauen in ein wohl einmaliges
Gemeindezentrum im ehemaligen Stall für
650 Kühe finden die Besucher heute hier
Läden mit regionalen Produkten
Werkstätten ein Hotel mit Restaurant und
Kaffee der Clue das ganze Gebäude ist
energieutak versorgt mit Strom und Wärme
aus Biogas Initiator für das Projekt ist
der exbürgermeister von bwig Berthold
[Musik]
Meer dass das Dorf heute in Zeiten der
Energiekrise so gut dasteht und sogar
Ausstellungen mit Künstlern aus der
Region veranstalten kann
seinen Ideen zu
verdanken wir haben keine Energiekrise
weil wir uns seit 2007 sag mal fast 2006
mit dem Thema beschäftigt haben wie wir
unsere eigenen energetischen Ressourcen
nutzen können das war eine riesen Frage
wenige hatten nur Erfahrung in dem
Bereich aber es war sehr schnell klar
Ressourcen haben wir genügend und wir
verbrauchen nicht mal alles wir erzeugen
sogar mehr Energie mittlerweile als wir
selber brauchen
[Musik]
wenn jetzt solche Veranstaltung hier
stattfinden
und man muss dann ein zwei Tage
vorheizen dann sind sind das bei Öl und
Gas Summen die da heute zustande kommen
dass man solche Veranstaltung gar nicht
mehr machen kann aber wir können es Gott
sei Dank mit den eigenen
Ressourcen und hier beginnt die
Wärmequelle von B
300 köhe im Kuhstall von Bauer Henk von
der ein gebürtiger
Niederländer sie liefern nicht nur Milch
sondern auch
Energie letztendlich ist es ja war die
Milchpreise in
27 und 2008 nicht auskömlich viele Milch
haben auch aufgegeben und wir haben uns
zweit stand gesucht
notfer bein das nicht nur den Bauern aus
der wirtschaftlichen Not geholfen hat
sondern das ganze Dorf mit Wärme und
Strom
versorgt wir müssen uns einfach was
ausdenken wo wir unsere Energie
produzieren meine Antwort draauf wir
produzieren das hier vor Ort wir haben
hier in relativ kleinen Betrieb
milbetrieb biosage integriert also
flexible geht ja nicht wir produzieren
unsere eigene Strom unsere eigene Wärme
Loer füris ganze Dorf und produzieren
eigene
Dünger nach harige geht ja nicht mit
diesem Prinzip hat die Gemeinde sich den
Titel Bioenergiedorf erworben in
Deutschland Wirtschaften inzwischen 160
Dörfer auf dieser Art der Bauer als
dörflicher
Energieversorger also hier fängt das ja
sozusagen an jeden Morgen um 10 Uhr wird
die rindegühle aufgerührt und rüber
gepumpt in die
Biogasanlage 25 Kubik pro
Tag das ist tagesfrische
Festmist und das landet jeden Tag bei
uns in die in der
Anlage undten te
Mais das ist eine Grassilage W extensive
Wiese und
maisilage von unser eigene
Ackerflächen das eigentliche Kraftwerk
ist in einem kleinen Raum neben den
Fermentern untergebracht mit der Gülle
von vier Küh kann Bauer van derhm so
viel Gas erzeugen um einen
vierpersenhaushalt mit Wärme und Strom
zu versorgen 600 kwatt leistet sein
Blockheizkraftwerk und produziert
günstige Energie für das ganze Dorf
unabhängig von ausländischen
Importen Biogas rein aus Mais ist aus
meine Sicht nicht unbedingt die beste
Lösung aber in Kombination mit dem
milfiebetrieb ist das ja eine super
Sache in Zeiten wenn die Milchpreise
schlecht sind kann der Betrieb ohne
Probleme weit geführt werden also sehr
gute zweite
Standbein Maisfelder im Norden
Deutschlands angebaut als
Energielieferant für Biogasanlagen die
Pflanzen liefern bei der vergehrung
besonders viel
Energie Bauern in Bayern nutzen
inzwischen silfen als Energiepflanzen
für
Biogasanlagen anders als Mais locken sie
mit ihren Blüten auch Insekten an und
tragen so mit zur Artenvielfalt
bei und so werden die Anlagen gefüllt 4%
kommt aus der Biomülltonne 5% sind
Reststoffe aus der Landwirtschaft Gülle
und Mist machen 18% aus und die
restlichen 73% stammen von
Energiepflanzen ganz überwiegend
[Musik]
Mais das stört besonders die Deutsche
Umwelthilfe ihr Lebensmittel gehören auf
den
Teller wenn wir uns umsehen dann stellen
wir fest dass wir aktuell in eine
Ernährungskrise sind in diesen Zeiten
Nahrungsmittel für Fermente oder den
Tank zu verschwenden ist nicht
nachvollziehbar ist nicht nachhaltig das
können wir nicht machen Fläche ist in
Deutschland ein rares Gut wenn wir
darauf Energiepflanzen anbauen einzig um
Energie zu erzeugen dann besetzen wir
große Teile der Ackerflächen auf der den
akerflächen sollte viel mehr
Nahrungsmittel angebaut werden die
Flächen sollten aber auch zur
Renaturierung zur Verfügung
stellen Nachschub für eine Biogasanlage
in Könnern Sachsen Anhalt 30 Landwirte
aus der Umgebung liefern die benötigte
maismenge zum Betrieb dieser
biomethanpark einer der größten Anlagen
weltweit produziert bereits seit 13
Jahren Energie die Argumente der
Umweltschützer teilt das Leipziger
BiomasseForschungsZentrum nicht hier in
Sachsen sachsenanal Thüringen da ist
genau das Gegenteil letztendes der Fall
da war man letztendes froh dass man mit
der
Biogastechnologie eine Verwertung für
Mais zur Verfügung hatte denn hier in
Ostdeutschland gab es durchaus
Fruchtfolgen die rein auf Getreide
basiert waren da hatte man genau das
Gegenteil als dichte Getreide
Fruchtfolge folgen und mit Mais konnte
man hier noch ein zusätzliches
fruchtvolgeglied
etablieren im Bundesumweltministerium
betrachtet man Biogasanlagen die mit
Energiepflanzen betrieben werden
besonders skeptisch aus unserer
Perspektive ist es sehr klar dass es vor
allem darum geht den Zubau an Biomasse
ja für Biogas jetzt nicht zu vollziehen
weil der einfach extreme nachhaltige
extrem nachhaltige Probleme produziert
im Lebensmittelsektor aber eben auch bei
der Frage der biologischen Vielfalt aber
auch für das Klima
selbst nach Berechnungen des
Umweltbundesamtes kann auf einem Hektar
genutzt mit Fotovoltaik oder Windkraft
30 bis 50 mal mehr Strom erzeugt werden
als aus einem Hektar mit Mais Mais ist
also eine sehr teure Form von
erneuerbarer
Energie der Anlagenbetreiber jens
alberartus hat wenig Verständnis für die
Diskussion die Diskussion wird ohne
Fakten geführt am Ende des Tages
mittlerweile haben wir fast 1000
Biogasanlagen in Deutschland gebaut und
diese werden ja auch betrieben die
Anlagen produzieren für 9,5 Millionen
Haushalte Strom wenn man eine andere
Zahl sieht dass wir für ungefähr fünf
mittelgroße Kernkraftwerke stehen kann
man das gar nicht verstehen warum wir
eine so untergeordnete Rolle
spielen die Betreiber beklagen dass
Biogas bei der Energiewende kaum
berücksichtigt werde dabei gehen sie
davon aus dass man die Leistung
verdreifachen
könnte Kritik auch am
Gesetzgeber die Gesetzesgebung in
anderen Ländern die ist viel freier und
flexibler wir stürzen uns hier in
Deutschland sehr sehr stark auf Produkte
aus der Landwirtschaft die extra für
Biogasanlagen produziert werden in
anderen Ländern dürfen Sie alles was
organischer Abfall ist oder organische
Stoffe sind zusammen mischen und zu
Energie umwandeln das dürfen sie in
Deutschland nicht zu machen das heißt
die Flexibilität in anderen Ländern ist
deutlich höher
die Förderung für Biogasanlagen hat sich
in den vergangenen 20 Jahren komplett
verändert zuerst hat die Politik Mais
als Energiepflanze unterstützt was zu
einem verstärkten Anbau führte 2014
wurde diese Förderung wieder gestrichen
weil Energiepflanzen durch Düngung
Pestizideinsatz nitratbelastungen und
Wasserverbrauch problematisch sind zudem
können der Klimawandel und dadurch
verursachte dürren zu Missernten führen
durch das Zurückfahren der
biogasförderung in Deutschland
expandiert die Branche verstärkt ins
Ausland eine Baustelle der
niedersächsischen Firma weltech in
England sie baut ihre Anlagen inzwischen
auch in Japan Australien den USA und
rund 25 weiteren
Ländern mit einem güllrporter unterwegs
in Dänemark
der Fahrer fährt zu Bauernhöfen im
Umkreis von 25 km von der Stadt espia
und pumpt die Gülle aus den Stellen in
seinen Tankwagen das geschieht voll
automatisch Dänemark ist Bauernland 60%
des Landes werden landwirtschaftlich
genutzt die wichtigsten Standbeine sind
Milchproduktion und Schweinemast da ist
es naheliegend die Gülle zu nutzen für
die Erzeugung von
Energie
das Ziel für den Fahrer die Biogasanlage
der Firma nature energy der größte
Produzent von Biomethan in Dänemark
50 solcher Anlagen stehen über das
kleine Land verteilt und weitere sind im
Bau oder in der
[Musik]
Planung Land es kommen jeden Tag etwa 40
bis 50 Lastwagen mit Biomasse von den
Bauern die Kühe oder Schweine haben hier
an hier oder da drüben laden Sie dann
Ihre Gülle aber auch Abfälle von der
Milch und Fleischindustrie
ab sie nehmen auch die ausgegaste Gülle
wieder mit und bringen Sie zu den Bauern
zurück die sie dann als Dünger auf ihren
Feldern wieder verteilen
können Dänemark treibt den Ausbau der
Biogaserzeugung massiv voran um die
Abhängigkeit von fossilem zu beenden
dabei setzt die Regierung auf
Großanlagen in den vergangenen 10 Jahren
hat Dänemark seine Produktion
verdreifacht anders als in Deutschland
wo sie
stagniert das Land hat den weltweit
höchsten Anteil von Biogas beim
Gasverbrauch wir haben das Prinzip dass
wir landwirtschaftliche Biomasse mit
Abfall wie Hausmüll
mischen das verbessert die
Methanproduktion
wir schauen uns also Biomasse Biomüll
breitgefächert an und entwickeln
Technologien die bewirken dass wir
Biomüll noch effektiver einsetzen
können das Potenzial von organischem
Abfall ist enorm wir nehmen auch den
Tieren nichts weg sondern nutzen nur
ihren Abfall und liefern grünen Dünger
aus unseren
Anlagen diese Anlage funktioniert wie
ein großer Industriebetrieb dieä sind
utomaier 500000 Tonnen Biomasse im Jahr
werden hier verarbeitet das funktioniert
nur weil es in Dänemark sehr viele
Schweinemastbetriebe gibt also
Massentierhaltung betrieben
wird Biomethan spielt bei uns schon seit
vielen Jahren eine große Rolle aber
durch den russischen Angriff auf die
Ukraine ist es noch mehr in den Fokus
gerückt im Jahr
2021ten
wir
g wir haben das Ziel dass bis spätestens
2030 Biogas 100% im dänischen
Energiesystem ausmachen
soll das hier gewonnene Gas ist
prinzipiell auch im Rest Europas
verfügbar denn das europäische Gasnetz
hängt zusammen die Dänen wollen ihr
Biogas nun auch in andere Länder Europas
exportieren n så
Biog bevor wir unser Biogas in das Netz
Pumpen reinigen wir es hier noch von
CO2 das kann dann in der
Lebensmittelindustrie verwendet
werden oder für
Trockeneis oder wenn du in der Kneipe
ein Bier trinkst wo Kohlensäure drin
ist das dänische System scheint für
Investoren interessant und lukrativ zu
werden der mulell hat die fir energy
jetzt
aufgekauft Dänemark eignet sich jedoch
nur bedingt als Vorbild für Deutschland
laut der Umweltorganisation NABU müssten
hier 450 Millionen Schweine in
Massentierhaltung Leben um eine
entsprechende Güllemenge zu
erhalten eine andere Möglichkeit Biogas
zu erzeugen ist Stroh getreidereste die
auf den Feldern sonst verrotten
würden eine Firma im brandenburgischen
Schwed hat dies Methode
entwickelt also das ist mittlerweile ein
sehr effizienter Prozess wir brauchen
mittlerweile noch drei solche
Strohballen um genügend Gas zu
produzieren damit man Mittelklasse Pkw
ein Jahr lang fahren kann also drei
solche Ballen und
95% CO2 neutral also besser geht's
nicht Autofahren mit Stroh im Tank
dieser Kraftstoff kann sehr viel CO2
einp
im Vergleich zu Benzin oder Diesel sagt
Firmenchef Klaus Sau doch gibt es genug
Nachschub in Deutschland sind ungefähr
20 Millionen Tonnen Stroh jedes Jahr die
nicht genutzt werden aber wenn man
dieses gesamte Stroh nehmen würde und
noch andere agrares Stoffe dann könnte
man so viel Gas produzieren hier in
Deutschland dass man ungefähr die Hälfte
des schweren Lkw Verkehrs mit Biomethan
aus Stroh betreiben könnte die Nutzung
von Stroh könnte also großes Potenzial
haben in Deutschland ist es nach Aussage
der Firma VERBIO ausreichend verfügbar
um etwa 10 Millionen Pkw auf den Betrieb
mit Biomethan umzustellen ich war immer
der Meinung dass das was wir hier
machen im Kampf gegen den Klimawandel
eigentlich eine gute Lösung ist aber das
bundesumwelttministerium sieht das
anders so und dieses permanente hin und
her mein wir haben jetzt seit 20 Jahren
erneuerbare Energien solar wind Biomasse
keiner sagt was wir eigentlich wollen
und wo wir hin wollen die
Bundesregierung sieht jedoch die
Ernährungskrise im
Vordergrund deswegen sagen wir als Haus
sehr sehr klar dass die Zukunft die
Mobilität ist gerade im pkwbereich für
die Logistikketten ist es sicherlich
anders aber da wird Wasserstoff in
Zukunft eine ganz zentrale Rolle spielen
und auch die werden wir sozusagen dann
stärker dadurch gewinnen dass wir eben
die ja den Strom aus Erneuerbaren
deutlich erhöhen müssen also den Ausbau
von Windkraft und PV deutlich
voranbringen während die Bundesregierung
also auf Wind Sonne und E-Mobilität
setzt Glauben an Biogas nur
wenige wie z.B dieser Verein der Biogas
für Autos fördern
möchte letzte Vorbereitungen für die
Eröffnung einer biogastankstelle bei
neus in
nordreheinwestfalen mit dabei der CNG
Club Deutschland CNG steht für
compressed natural gas mit diesem
Kraftstoff könne man klimaneutral
unterwegs sein der Landwirt Daniel
Königs erzeugt das Biogas für den
autoantrieb auf seiner hofeigenen
Biogasanlage den Kraftstoff kann man
hier in Deutschland produzieren das
beste Beispiel ist hier diese Eröffnung
er macht den Verbrenner grün die gesamte
Wertschöpfungskette bei diesem
Kraftstoff bleibt in Deutschland und es
sind 130 oktaren man fährt ganz normal
Auto man ist klimaneutral und vor allen
Dingen auch noch günstig unterwegs doch
das Interesse unter den Autofahrern ist
gering nur gut 900 CNG Tankstellen gibt
es in Deutschland und relativ wenige
Erdgasautos das Besondere an dieser
Tankstelle das Gas wird aus Pferdemist
gewonnen dieser kommt aus der Umgebung
und wird auch gleich neben der
Tankstelle in einer Biogasanlage
umgewandelt Mist von 1500 Pferden aus
der Nachbarschaft wird hier täglich
verarbeitet mit dem daraus gewonnenen
Gas könnte ein Mittelklasse Auto gut
50.000 km weit fahren doch die Betreiber
Zielen mit ihrer biogastankstelle mehr
auf den Fuhrpark von Speditionen
Baufirmen oder kommunalen Unternehmen
diese Fahrzeugflotten bilden einen
speziellen Markt der sich mit Biogas gut
bedienen ließe deren Vertreter zeigen
zwar großes Interesse an Biogas dennoch
geht der Tankstellenbetreiber ein Risiko
ein die Politik verunsicherheit uns al
das ist unser größtes Risiko ist weder
die die Praxistauglichkeit noch die
Wirtschaftlichkeit sondern wirklich die
Politik die wenn die jetzt hingeht und
sagt ja wir wollen nur noch Elektro LKWs
und nur Wasserstoff LKWs dann könnte
dann so ein Projekt wie wir das hier
machen dass wir den Kraftstoff in dieser
Region produzieren dann auch wieder
kaputt gemacht werden also wir vernehmen
natürlich ganz ganz stark von der
Politik die Priorisierung auf das ganze
Thema
ebobilität was wir sehr schade finden
weil es gibt Technologien sind viel viel
gereifter und schon früher da zuem es
auch eine Infrastruktur gibt ja und wenn
sie sich mal die Förderprogramme
anschauen und welchen listpreis man wir
für ein Elektro LKW tatsächlich nenn es
mal so hinblättern müssen im Vergleich
zu Technologie die wir hier haben die
absolut nachhaltig ist dann ist das
teilweise sehr fragwürdig für uns ist es
viel leichter Invest zu tätigen für 30
40 LKWs in so eine Technologie als über
fast 16 Millionen Euro hinzu Blättern
für vielleicht 40 e Autos oder e-elektro
LKWs die fast 400000 € pro Stück
kosten ein mit gasbetriebener LKW
gleicher Größe kostet dagegen etwa
150.000
€ bei der Müllabfuhr in Berlin ist die
Entscheidung längst gefallen der eigene
Fuhrpark wird bereits mit
selbsterzeugtem Biogas betankt die
Einsparung 2,5 Millionen Liter Diesel
pro Jahr
[Musik]
und die kleine Gemeinde
bwig sie wächst dank
Biogas eine neue Siedlung ist bereits
entstanden ein weiteres Baugebiet ist in
Vorbereitung vor Jahren haben wir
gedacht das wird gar nicht mehr bebaut
und mit einmal sind Leute da die das
auch erschließen wollen und eben diese
Vorteile von blewig nutzen wollen und
sofern ist aus meiner Sicht sehr wichtig
gerade auch für junge Leute dass sie
eine gute Infrastruktur vorfinden und
das fängt natürlich bei Strom Wasser
Abwasser als auch bei Wärmeversorgung
Energie bis hin zum Internet Berthold
Meer hat sein Ziel erreicht seine
Energiewende funktioniert ich möchte
gerne dass die Energiewende von unten
kommen mit den Menschen wir waren schon
mal weiter und und jetzt müssen wir nur
umso schneller werden weil wir wissen
was fürs Klima notwendig ist
lokalangegewendet wie hier in blewig
kann Biogas eine sinnvolle Lösung sein
und somit ein Teil der
Energiewende auch wenn Biomethan das
russische Gas nicht ersetzen wird kann
es helfen Energieimporte zu
[Musik]
verringern